what's enough maggots it's gonna take  more than holding the trigger win this  war I'm here to show you some advanced  tactics use your elite training elevate  surprise your unsuspecting enemy gas  tanks are faceted military tanks ride  down to victory  shoddy third wall construction is our  ally bring it down and watch some bodies  crumble return anemic innate sir  strategic boom delicious give our  enemies a taste of freedom with our  superior American cuisine  that's great use the enemy's own  stockpiles against some and watch those  bastards go down in a blaze of democracy  go to war with four rows at a time and  in recent I hell  use special attacks of bringing pain  imprints terrorism rain in general